sauf que là j'ai de cerner son plan
c'est à dire c'est à dire qu'on va le
prendre à son propre jeu c'est à dire je
te le dire non mais des fois je prends
mon compte tellement à fond de la pêche
pour faire bon poids de prendre à son
propre jeu mais c'est vrai sur moi
[Musique]
dit on est obligé d'aller dans un
entrepôt mais comme ça et on dirait un
décor de film
ben voila je le sentais ya pas de réseau
un [ __ ] de héros mort j'étais une
petite angoisse mais ça va mieux ça dit
qu'elle j'ai tout pour l' angoisse passé
le casting pour jouer un film à
hollywood mec jaloux
on a tout seul j'ai vu ça des grandes
cornes
des grands yeux
est ce que quelqu'un un mouchoir ta
gueule elle a montré moins votre côté
pienaar
[Musique]
oh
alors quelle est la cible mammifères ou
d'êtres humains avant la pire soirée de
toute ma vie
bon
non mais non armées
toutes mes oies à bravo à toute l'équipe
c'était super mais pas de monstre
c'était une mise en scène en question il
pas longtemps j'ai peu roulé mais
c'était
ah [ __ ] tu pars
tous quel bar tu parles